Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Good sirs, good ladies, many years of happy days before thee, and welcome unto The Rest Is History. And if you are wondering why I'm introducing this in a kind of cod Shakespearean style, it's because, Dominic Sandbrook, we're going to do a Tudor-themed show, aren't we? And this is the first one we've done, actually, since The Six Wives of Henry VIII, which we did a year ago. Seems kind of disgraceful. It's very unusual that British historians stay off the Tudors.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社群，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。各位先生，各位女士，愿你们拥有充满快乐时光的岁月，欢迎来到《历史的余烬》。如果你在纳闷为什么我要用一种莎士比亚式的腔调来开场，多米尼克·桑德布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook），那是因为我们要做一个都铎王朝主题的节目，对吧？实际上，这是我们自一年前制作“亨利八世的六位妻子”以来，第一次做这个主题。感觉有点说不过去。英国历史学家竟然把都铎王朝撇在一边，这非常罕见。
Yes, it is. Before we come to the theme of what we're talking about today, and of course you already know because I'm sure you'll have seen the title of this episode, but I want to kick off, Dominic, by asking you a question. And I want you to imagine that both of us have been taken back in a time machine to Tudor England. And due to a complicated degree of circumstances, which I won't go into, we've been presented to the privy council and the privy council have to decide which of us would make the best king right who do you think they would go for obviously i think they'd go for me i mean why do you think they go for you i mean beyond the fact that you enjoy attacking the french and all that kind of stuff but there's one fundamental reason why they would probably choose you over me.
是的，确实如此。在我们进入今天的话题之前——当然你们肯定已经知道了，因为我相信你们一定看过这期节目的标题——但我想要开个头，多米尼克，问你一个问题。我想让你想象一下，我们俩都被时间机器带回了都铎王朝的英格兰。由于一系列复杂的情况（我就不细讲了），我们被引见给了枢密院，枢密院必须决定我们俩谁能成为最好的国王。你觉得他们会选谁？显然，我觉得他们会选我。我的意思是，你为什么觉得他们会选你？除了你喜欢攻击法国人之类的事情之外，有一个根本原因，他们可能会选你而不是我。
Is there? I think, I mean, maybe I'm just flattering myself, Tom, but I think they would see that I would, I would take the necessary tough decisions for the stability of the realm. And I think,
是吗？我想，也许我只是在往自己脸上贴金，汤姆，但我认为他们会看出我，我会为了王国的稳定做出必要的艰难决定。而且我认为，
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. It's nothing to do with that. Surely.
对，对，对，对，对，对。这肯定跟那个没关系。
What is the main duty of a Tudor King? To have a son. To have a son. And you have a son and not king? To have a son. To have a son. And you have a son. And not only do you have a son, but you've called him Arthur. Yeah. So like Henry VII's eldest son. Whereas I, I have two daughters. Two daughters.
都铎王朝国王的主要职责是什么？生个儿子。生个儿子。而你有一个儿子，不是国王？生个儿子。生个儿子。你有一个儿子。不仅你有一个儿子，而且你还给他取名叫亚瑟。是的。就像亨利七世的长子那样。而我，我有两个女儿。两个女儿。
Useless. Absolutely useless. Both of whom have impeccably Tudor names. So Katie, Catherine and Eliza Elizabeth. But no good, really. No. And this takes us, does it not, to the heart of what we're talking about today,
毫无用处。绝对毫无用处。而且这两个女儿都有着无可挑剔的都铎式名字。凯蒂，凯瑟琳，以及伊莱扎，伊丽莎白。但真的没什么用。不。这就让我们引出了今天讨论的核心，不是吗？
which is Lady Jane Grey, the Nine Days Queen. Although whether she was really Lady Jane Grey, whether she was really a Nine Days Queen, we can discuss that. And she, Dominic, I know that you've been doing furious amounts of research for this. Do you want to just kind of give the listeners a kind of just a very quick synopsis of the basic outline of the plot before we start looking at some of the characters and the detail of what happened? Okay, sure. So we
那就是简·格雷女士（Lady Jane Grey），九日女王。尽管她是不是真的是简·格雷女士，她是不是真的是一位九日女王，我们可以讨论这一点。而且，多米尼克，我知道你为此做了大量的研究。在你开始介绍一些人物和事情的细节之前，你想不想给听众们非常简单地概述一下情节的基本大纲？好的，没问题。所以我们
are in the year 1553. And the King of England is Edward VI. So that is the son of Henry VIII. It's the son for whom Henry VIII waited and prayed so long. Henry VIII had three children, Mary, Elizabeth, and Edward. And it is young Edward, a teenager, who is king. And he has presided over the sort of white heat of the Protestant
正处于1553年。当时的英格兰国王是爱德华六世。也就是亨利八世的儿子。就是亨利八世等待并祈祷了那么久的那个儿子。亨利八世有三个孩子：玛丽、伊丽莎白和爱德华。年轻的爱德华登基时还是个十几岁的少年，他国王。他见证了英格兰新教
Reformation in England. It's furious, isn't it? Blazing. Yeah. So, extraordinary period of kind of religious and cultural revolution, I think you could call it. But Edward dies unexpectedly on the 6th of July. And just a few days later, instead of proclaiming his sister Mary, as a lot of people expected as queen, the Privy Council, that's the body, the sort of repository of authority in the realm, they proclaim somebody else who's not expected, and that person is Lady Jane Grey.
改革的炽热阶段。非常狂热，对吧？烈火熊熊。是的。所以，这是一段非同寻常的宗教和文化革命时期，我想你可以这么称呼它。但爱德华在7月6日意外去世。仅仅几天后，枢密院并没有像许多人预期的那样宣布他的姐姐玛丽为女王——枢密院就是那个机构，王国权力的某种保管库——而是宣布了另一个出乎意料的人，那个人就是简·格雷女士。
And for, it's actually, I mean, everyone remembers her as the nine-day queen, but for 13 days, she is Queen of England, while Mary is outraged and says, this is a terrible usurpation, I should be queen. Jane appears to have the backing of the most powerful man in the realm, the Duke of Northumberland, her father-in-law. And I think most people probably think that she will prevail, but she doesn't. Her support melts away. Mary is able to come into London.
而且实际上——我的意思是，每个人都记得她是“九日女王”，但她作为英格兰女王其实有13天。与此同时，玛丽感到被激怒了，说这是一次可怕的篡位，我才应该是女王。简似乎得到了王国中最有权势的人——她的公公诺森伯兰公爵的支持。我想大多数人可能认为她会胜出，但她没有。支持她的人纷纷倒戈。玛丽得以进入伦敦。
The Privy Council change sides. They back Mary after all. Bells and bon come into London. The Privy Council change sides. They back Mary after all. Bells and bonfires in London. Poor old Jane is locked up in the tower. And several months later, the beginning of 1554, poor old Jane, who is just a teenager, probably 15 or so, she has her head cut off. And the great thing about Jane is that she is Queen of England, but she is never in the lists, Tom. So this is one of the great controversies about Jane. Is she Queen or isn't she? Okay. So, yes. So we've had lots of questions on basically on that line. Sandra Fearon can stand in for everybody else. Should
枢密院倒戈了。他们最终还是支持了玛丽。伦敦到处都是钟声和篝火。可怜的简被关进了塔楼。几个月后，也就是1554年初，可怜的简——她还只是个十几岁的女孩，可能也就15岁左右——被砍了头。简最了不起的地方在于，她是英格兰女王，但她却从未出现在官方名单上，汤姆。所以这也是关于简的一大争议所在。她究竟算不算女王？好吧。所以，是的。因此我们收到了很多基本上围绕这个方向的问题。桑德拉·菲伦（Sandra Fearon）可以代表其他人提问。简·格雷女士
Lady Jane Grey be considered Queen? So you think she should be? Yes and no, I think is the very evasive answer. Well, let's come to that at the end of the show. So essentially, to understand this whole extraordinary incident, there are really kind of two major strands to the story, aren't there? The first is the fact that everywhere you look in the Tudor line of succession, there are women rather than men, girls rather than boys. And this in an age where it is assumed that men should be king and that women shouldn't rule is a real problem. And the other is what you alluded to in your account about Edward VI's white-hot Protestantism, because Mary is a Catholic. And so it's the tensions between Catholic and Protestant. It's the religious loyalties of the various candidates to become monarch that also kind of interacts with the
应该被视为女王吗？所以你认为她应该是？我的回答非常含糊：既是也不是。好吧，让我们在节目结束时再来探讨这个问题。所以本质上，要理解这起非同寻常的事件，这个故事其实有两个主要的支线，对吧？第一支线是：你在都铎王朝的王位继承序列中放眼望去，到处都是女性而不是男性，都是女孩而不是男孩。在一个默认男性应该当国王、女性不应该统治的时代，这是一个真正的问题。而另一个支线，正如你在描述爱德华六世那炽热的新教信仰时所暗示的那样，因为玛丽是个天主教徒。因此，这是天主教徒和新教徒之间的紧张关系。成为君主的各个候选人的宗教信仰，也与这个
narrative. Absolutely, Tom. Yeah. And so really, if we're beginning the story, we need to go back to Henry VIII and the theme of our last Tudor episode, which was on his attempt to, you know, he had all these wives basically because he was trying to get a son, didn't he? So he had Catherine of Aragon gave him Mary, who was raised Catholic, stayed Catholic. Anne Boleyn, Protestant bride, gives him another daughter, Elizabeth, who was raised a Protestant. And then Jane Seymour, his third wife, gives him at last the long-awaited boy who becomes Edward and who is raised as a very, very hot Protestant indeed. Yeah, that's absolutely right. I think the Lady Jane Grey story, Tom, it's an absolutely brilliant story for a podcast, because it's kind of a who and why done it. Historians disagree about who was behind the coup, who was actually carrying out, is the coup by Jane or is the coup by Mary? And at the heart of it is this girl, this teenage girl
叙事相互交织。绝对是这样，汤姆。是的。所以，如果我们从头讲起，我们需要回到亨利八世，以及我们上一个都铎王朝主题节目的核心——他试图……你知道，他之所以有这么多妻子，基本上是因为他试图生个儿子，对吧？所以他有阿拉贡的凯瑟琳，给他生了玛丽，玛丽是在天主教环境中抚养长大的，也一直信奉天主教；安妮·博林，一个新教新娘，给他生了另一个女儿伊丽莎白，伊丽莎白是按新教方式抚养长大的；然后是简·西摩，他的第三个妻子，终于给他生下了期待已久的男孩，也就是爱德华，他被培养成了一个非常非常狂热的新教徒。是的，完全正确。汤姆，我认为简·格雷女士的故事，是一个做成播客的绝佳故事，因为它有点像个“谁干的”和“为什么干的”的悬疑剧。历史学家们对谁是政变的幕后黑手意见不一，究竟是谁在实际执行——这场政变是简发动的，还是玛丽发动的？而这一切的核心，是这个女孩，这个失去了生命的
who loses her life. So it's an amazing story. But beyond that, this is an absolute hinge moment in English history. I mean, if Jane had succeeded, no Mary, so no reversion to Catholicism, no Elizabeth, potentially no House of Stuart. English history really does take a different path. But at the heart of it, I completely agree with you you is henry the eighth he overshadows the whole story and it's his i don't think you understand the tudors unless you understand that the sort of the insecurity of the tudor regime because they are parvenus aren't they i mean they came in in 1485 with henry's father and i think we talked about this in the when we're talking about the six wives of henry the eighth that Henry, this thing about the son, which actually I think to 21st century listeners always seems a bit comical, doesn't it?
十几岁的女孩。所以这是一个惊人的故事。不仅如此，这也是英国历史上的一个绝对转折点。我的意思是，如果简成功了，就没有玛丽，也就没有重回天主教，没有伊丽莎白，潜在地也没有斯图亚特王朝。英国历史确实会走上一条不同的道路。但在这个故事的核心，我完全同意你的看法，那就是亨利八世。他笼罩着整个故事，如果你不理解都铎王朝政权的某种不安全感，你就无法理解都铎王朝，因为他们是暴发户，对吧？我的意思是，他们是在1485年随着亨利（七世）的父亲入主伦敦的。我想我们在谈论“亨利八世的六位妻子”时讨论过这一点，关于亨利对生儿子的执念——这在21世纪的听众看来，其实总是显得有点滑稽，对吧？
It's always got the sort of hint of Sid James about it, I must have a son and all this stuff. But actually… Well, and sexist probably. And sexist, of course it seems sexist. But the truth of the matter is, if Henry feels that if he doesn't have that son and if the Tudor line doesn't go down the male sort of branches, then everything his father did would have been for nothing,
总让人联想到那种西德·詹姆斯（Sid James）式的调侃，我必须得有个儿子之类的话。但实际上……嗯，而且可能很大男子主义。大男子主义，这听起来当然很大男子主义。但事实是，如果亨利觉得，如果他没有那个儿子，如果都铎王朝的血脉不能延续下去，那么他父亲所做的一切就都白费了，
everything their family did. So his father, Henry VII, risking everything in this kind of mad adventure and winning the crown at the Battle of Bosworth. If Henry VIII doesn't have a son, doesn't pass the crown to a boy, then he thinks I'll have let down the family and we'll have wasted our time. And it's not just because the only real example of a female ruler is Matilda back in the 12th century, who never kind of became universally accepted. She fought the war with Stephen, this kind of terrible civil war, and her son, who never kind of became universally accepted. She fought the war with
他们家族所做的一切也都白费了。因此，他的父亲亨利七世在这场疯狂的冒险中押上了一切，并在博斯沃思战役中赢得了王冠。如果亨利八世没有儿子，没有把王冠传给一个男孩，那么他就会觉得，我对不起家族，我们白白浪费了时间。这不仅是因为唯一的女性统治者现实例子是12世纪的玛蒂尔达（Matilda），她从未真正被普遍接受。她与斯蒂芬打了一场可怕的内战，她的儿子……她从未真正被普遍接受。她与斯蒂芬打了一场可怕的
Stephen, this kind of terrible civil war, and her son, Henry II, ended up becoming king, but she herself was never fully acknowledged as a queen. And so that is a kind of shadow that hangs over it, that there is an association between the idea of a female ruler with civil war. So that is obviously something that Henry worries about. But there's also the fact that, as he says, if the female heir shall chance to rule, she cannot continue long without a husband, which by God's law must then be her governor and head. So for Henry, that is an emasculating prospect that his bloodline should become subject to whoever marries, say Mary or say Elizabeth. And particularly if that's a foreign king,
内战，她的儿子亨利二世最终成为了国王，但她自己从未被完全认可为女王。所以这是一种悬在头顶的阴影，人们把女性统治者的概念与内战联系在一起。因此，这显然是亨利所担心的事情。但还有一个事实正如他所说：“如果女性继承人偶然执政，没有丈夫她就无法长久，而根据上帝的法律，丈夫必须成为她的统治者和首领。”对亨利来说，这是一种被阉割的前景，即他的血脉会受制于任何娶了玛丽或伊丽莎白的人。特别是如果那是一个外国国王，
then that's a real problem, not just for Henry, but for England as well. So the stakes are very high. We'll see that with Jane, we'll see that with Mary, and we'll see that with Elizabeth, this issue of the husband. If you have a husband, he will try to rule and people will start to judge you by the husband. So that issue absolutely hangs over. It's not just Henry who thinks so. Again, it's very easy for the 21st century to assume this sort of grotesque whale, the sexist whale is projecting his own weird sexual inadequacies onto Tudor England. Most people in Tudor England, I think, unquestionably think that the king, there should be a king, he should be a man. And if it's a woman, then her husband will inevitably take over. But of course, actually, Tom, when Henry dies, he has the son.
那将是一个真正的难题，不仅对亨利来说是这样，对英格兰来说也是如此。因此，赌注非常高。我们会在简身上看到这一点，在玛丽身上看到这一点，也会在伊丽莎白身上看到这一点，这就是关于“丈夫”的问题。如果你有一个丈夫，他会试图统治，人们就会开始根据你的丈夫来评判你。所以这个问题绝对挥之不去。不仅亨利这么认为。同样，21世纪的人很容易认为，这种怪诞的哀叹——这种大男子主义的哀叹——是将他自己怪异的性功能不足投影到了都铎王朝的英格兰。我认为，都铎王朝英格兰的大多数人，毫无疑问地认为国王应该是一个男人。如果是一个女性，那么她的丈夫将不可避免地接管权力。但当然，事实上，汤姆，当亨利去世时，他确实有一个儿子。
And that's Edward VI. Yeah, he does have the son. But just before we come on to Edward and his rule, because Edward is a boy, but almost everywhere else you look there's nothing but girls you know that the two other children Mary and Elizabeth that Henry's had are girls um Henry VIII has two sisters so you know if you if you're going back and you're looking at the children of Henry VII he has two sisters he has Margaret who marries the King of Scotland her heir is Mary who's married the King of France um who will become the king of scotland her heir is mary who's married the king of france um who will become mary queen of scott who is mary queen of scotts will be commemorated as
那就是爱德华六世。是的，他确实有个儿子。但在我们谈到爱德华及其统治之前——因为爱德华是个男孩，但几乎在你看向其他任何地方时，除了女孩别无所有——你知道亨利生下的另外两个孩子玛丽和伊丽莎白都是女孩。嗯，亨利八世有两个姐姐，所以如果你回顾并寻找亨利七世的孩子，他有两个姐姐：他有玛格丽特，嫁给了苏格兰国王，她的继承人是玛丽，玛丽嫁给了法国国王，嗯，玛丽将成为苏格兰女王——玛丽·斯图亚特将被纪念为
mary queen of scott so there's a there is a girl yeah um then you have um mary who herself had actually very briefly been queen of france she comes back she and she marries um henry's best friend charles brandon the earl of suffk, who is absolutely lad, isn't he? He's very much a red trouser man, I think. He's the kind of friend that Prince Harry had before he met Meghan. Precisely. He's definitely a pre-Meghan friend. So Henry and Charles are kind of together. Charles, Charles,
玛丽·斯图亚特——所以有一个女孩。嗯，然后你还有玛丽，她自己其实非常短暂地做过法国女王。她回来后，她嫁给了亨利最好的朋友查尔斯·布兰登（Charles Brandon），萨福克伯爵，他绝对是个花花公子，不是吗？我觉得他非常像那种穿着艳丽裤子的时髦男人。他就是哈里王子在遇到梅根之前会交的那种朋友。没错。他绝对是个“遇见梅根前”的朋友。所以亨利和查尔斯差不多形影不离。查尔斯、查尔斯·
Brandon and, and Mary have a daughter inevitably Francis. Yeah. And Francis then in turn has inevitably three daughters. So everywhere you look, there are, you know, it's a,
布兰登和玛丽不可避免地生了一个女儿，弗朗西斯（Francis）。是的。然后弗朗西斯反过来又不可避免地生了三个女儿。所以放眼望去，到处都是，
it's a female. And so that then makes Edward the sixth absolutely fundamental as it seems to those who think that, you know it's a it's a female alliance and so that then makes edward the sixth absolutely fundamental as it seems to those who think that you know a a regnant female would be a disaster it makes it makes him absolutely key to the stability of the kingdom it is um and he's actually a very promising heir for henry so edward the sixth is also at the centre of this story. So he's nine years old when he becomes king, but he has probably had the best education that any English monarch has ever had. He's had the absolute finest tutors. He can speak loads of languages. Everybody says he's very clever. Because he later dies young, there's often a perception that Edward VI must have been
这是一个女性的世界。这就让爱德华六世变得绝对至关重要——在那些认为女性摄政将是一场灾难的人看来，这让爱德华六世变得绝对关键，关乎王国的稳定。确实如此。对于亨利来说，他实际上是一个非常有前途的继承人，所以爱德华六世也是这个故事的中心。他九岁时成为国王，但他可能接受过任何英国君主从未有过的最佳教育。他拥有绝对最优秀的家庭教师。他会说多种语言。每个人都说他非常聪明。因为他后来英年早逝，人们往往有一种看法，认为爱德华六世一定是个
this kind of sickly weed, a pale weed. I mean, that's basically what I was brought up believing in the textbooks. Actually, this is completely wrong. He sometimes was ill, but people were always ill in Tudor England. He appears to be, as a teenager, perfectly robust, independent-minded, very intelligent. And the Protestantism. Very steely. Yeah. He's really dead keen on this. I mean, he believes it. Yes. And the Protestantism, I mean, because Henry had obviously thought that he was God's agent, but Edward really believes that because he stands at the head of this radical process of reform.
那种病弱的废柴、苍白的废柴。我的意思是，教科书上基本上就是这么教导我的。实际上，这完全是错误的。他有时确实生病，但在都铎王朝的英格兰，人们总是生病。作为一个少年，他看起来非常健壮、思想独立、非常聪明。还有那种新教信仰。非常坚定。是的。他对此非常热衷。我是说，他是真的信仰这个。是的。关于新教信仰，因为亨利显然认为自己是上帝的代理人，但爱德华是真心实意地这样认为的，因为他站在了这场激进改革运动的最前沿。
Yeah. So he's been in for four or five years, and they have been sort of stripping out images. They have been getting rid of the last relics. They have been abolishing rituals. Henry VIII, deep down, I think it's fair to say, Tom, and of course, this is a massive simplification. He had broken with Rome about his marriage, but deep down, he was still ideologically, as it were, a Catholic. Edward VI, that's not true at all. This is the real turning point. Yeah. I mean, Edward is kind of like, you know, he's been off to study, to do gender studies at an elite Ivy League university. And he's come back and it's all about, you know, pronouns and decolonization and everything. And that is absolutely what he's about.
是的。所以他执政四五年了，他们一直在清除偶像。他们一直在摆脱最后的圣物。他们一直在废除仪式。亨利八世内心深处，我认为可以公平地说，汤姆——当然这是一种极大的简化——他曾因婚姻问题与罗马决裂，但内心深处，他在意识形态上仍然是个天主教徒。爱德华六世可完全不是这样。这才是真正的转折点。是的。我的意思是，爱德华有点像那种……你知道的，他去一所精英常春藤盟校研究了性别研究。然后他回来了，满脑子都是代词、去殖民化之类的一切。这绝对就是他所关心的。
He's at the kind of the cutting edge of elite education, elite cultural trends, the fervour of purifying and cleansing England of this kind of great taint of sin. And of course, he's the agent of people who think that as well. But he really is his own man. I mean, he really believes this stuff. And he is desperate, therefore, when he falls ill, doesn't he, in, what is it, 1553. As he starts to, you know, he's what, 15, I think he's 15 then, is he? And so this matters hugely to him. It does, yeah.
他处于精英教育、精英文化潮流的最前沿，满腔热忱地要净化和清洗英格兰，洗刷这种罪恶的巨大污点。当然，他也是那些持有这种想法的人的代理人。但他真的是个有主见的人。我是说他是真心相信这些东西的。因此，当他在1553年（是多少年？）生病时，他感到极其绝望。当他开始……你知道的，他那时多大？他当时15岁，我想。所以这对他来说至关重要。确实，是的。
That the revolution not be turned back. Absolutely. So he's at the centre of this. He's not the feckless, sickly weed. So at the beginning of the year, Edward VI appears to be in great health. New Year, they have all their usual kind of, you know, I know you love a court mask, Tom.
他绝不能让这场革命开倒车。绝对的。所以他处于这个故事的中心。他不是个软弱无能、病恹恹的废柴。所以在年初，爱德华六世看起来身体非常健康。新年时，他们有所有那些惯常的……我知道你喜欢宫廷假面舞会，汤姆。
I love a court mask. They have all their court masks there's much fooling yeah there's great tomfoolery you know there's people there's jesters there's people wearing the wrong trousers it's a great tremendous time the last flow right but in february he gets a very bad cold which sounds like nothing to us, but in the 1550s, you get a very bad cold and it goes into your lungs, you could well die. And basically, it seems likely that he got some lung infection that he just couldn't shake off and it became more and more deep seated, and it's going to end up killing him. And what seems to have happened, so this is a really complicated story and really interesting.
我喜欢宫廷假面舞会。他们有所有的宫廷假面舞会，有很多恶作剧。是的，有极大的滑稽表演，你知道的，有人们，有小丑，有人穿着奇装异服，那是一个非常棒、非常了不起的时期，最后的狂欢，对吧？但在2月，他得了重感冒，这在我们看来似乎不算什么，但在1550年代，你得了重感冒，如果病菌进入肺部，你很可能会死。基本上，看起来很可能是他得了某种肺部感染，怎么也治不好，并且病情越来越深，最终要了他的命。而似乎发生的事情是——所以这是一个非常复杂且非常有趣的故事。
What seems to have happened is that a few weeks into this illness, he starts to think about, well, what happens if I die? And probably at this stage, he's thinking about this as a long-term thing because he starts to work out what he calls his device for the succession. Because he obviously isn't married. He's 15 and he's got no children and the first version of this basically says um it will go the crown will go to the male heirs of my cousin lady jane gray who will come to in a second we haven't gone on to her yet so the question tom is why doesn't he want his sisters to get it, Mary or Elizabeth? Mary is obvious. She's Catholic. But we have a question here from Andrea with the bangs. Why did Edward VI name Lady Jane as his successor rather than his sister Elizabeth? Because Elizabeth is Protestant. So what's the problem with Elizabeth?
似乎发生的事情是，在他生病的几周后，他开始思考：“好吧，如果我死了会怎么样？”可能在这个阶段，他把这当作长远的事情来考虑，因为他开始着手制定他所谓的“王位继承计划”（device for the succession）。因为他显然还没结婚。他才15岁，没有孩子，而这个计划的第一个版本基本上说……王位将传给我表妹简·格雷女士的男性后嗣——我们一会儿就会讲到她，我们还没讲到她呢。所以问题是，汤姆，为什么他不想让他的姐姐们继承？玛丽还是伊丽莎白？玛丽很明显。她是天主教徒。但我们这里有一个顶着齐刘海的安德烈（Andrea）提出的问题：为什么爱德华六世指定简女士为继承人，而不是他的姐姐伊丽莎白？因为伊丽莎白是新教徒。那伊丽莎白有什么问题呢？
This is a brilliant question because it's not because, I think the answer is because it's not just about religion. So let's talk about those two characters. I mean, this is before either of them a queen. So of course, everyone would have heard of Bloody Mary and Good Queen Bess, but they're not yet those characters. So Mary, first of all, daughter of Catherine of Aragon, she's 37. She's had an absolutely terrible life to this point she's seen her mother you know um she's been she's been parted from her mother she and her mother die of cancer alone you know she has been ostracized she's been told that she's illegitimate um you know people have treated her as a sort of punch bag she is a sort of short thin thin, very insecure, very miserable person who's basically been a victim and been abused and ignored all her life. And she was actually Edward's godmother, wasn't she?
这是一个绝妙的问题，因为答案不仅关乎宗教。让我们来谈谈这两个人物。我的意思是，这是在她俩成为女王之前。所以当然，每个人都听说过“血腥玛丽”和“贤明女王贝丝”，但她们当时还不是那些形象。所以玛丽，首先，她是阿拉贡凯瑟琳的女儿，她已经37岁了。到目前为止，她过着极其悲惨的生活。她看到自己的母亲……你知道的……她被迫与母亲分离，她和她的母亲孤独地死于癌症（译者注：此处历史细节略有出入，凯瑟琳死于癌症疑似，玛丽未因癌症独死）。她遭到流放，被告知自己是个私生子……你知道的，人们把她当成出气筒。她是一个身材矮小、瘦弱、极度缺乏安全感、非常痛苦的人，基本上她一辈子都在扮演受害者，饱受虐待和忽视。她其实是爱德华的教母，对吧？
She was, yeah. And she's what, kind of 30 years older than him? Yeah, because Jane Seymour had been very nice to her and had brought her back into the fold. Mary, I'll tell you an interesting thing about Mary. She has a very deep voice. Oh, I didn't know that. But she very very slight isn't she but with a good voice but everyone actually says although the bloody Mary she's very kind Tom did you know that she's very I did know that yes I did I'm I'm I'm very much team Mary of course you are because you're
是的，没错。她比他大多少？大概大30岁吧？是的，因为简·西摩对她很好，把她接回了家族。玛丽——我告诉你关于玛丽的一个有趣的事。她的声音非常低沉。哦，我不知道这个。但她身形非常非常娇小，对吧，不过声音很好听。但每个人都说，尽管她是“血腥玛丽”，但她其实非常善良，汤姆，你知道吗？她非常……我确实知道，是的，我知道。我……我绝对是玛丽阵营的，当然。你当然是，因为你
unsound on the reformation well in in this I am um but I mean, imagine the kind of the nightmare, if you're a devout Catholic, of having a 10-year-old boy hectoring you about changing your religion. Do you know what? They have massive rows when he's king. He will kind of call her in. I mean, imagine, yeah, he's nine or 10.
对宗教改革的立场不太稳。好吧，在这个问题上我是这样的……但我的意思是，想象一下那种噩梦——如果你是一个虔诚的天主教徒，却有一个10岁的男孩对你颐指气使，要你改变宗教信仰。你知道吗？当他是国王时，他们曾有过激烈的争吵。他会把她叫来……想象一下，是的，他才9岁或10岁。
It's kind of like your worst Christmas, isn't it? And says, stop celebrating mass. Stop associating with Catholic priests. He's nine or ten. It's kind of like your worst Christmas, isn't it? And says, stop celebrating mass. Stop associating with Catholic priests. You're an absolute, you know. And they will both have. Stop it. They'll both be in floods of tears, apparently.
这有点像你过得最糟糕的一个圣诞节，对吧？然后对她说：“停止庆祝弥撒。停止与天主教神父交往。你简直是个……”他们俩都会……停下。显然，他们俩都会泪流满面。
I mean, in her case, it surely, as you say, must be tears of absolute rage. Who is this little? She's a grown woman. I mean, she's 30. woman i mean she's she's 30 i command thee yeah this is splendid historical analysis tom very good um so there's him sorry there's her there's mary but then there's elizabeth as well now elizabeth is 20 and of course she is protestant so the question is why didn't he just skip? And I think there are two, to Elizabeth, and I think there are two reasons that are the core of this.
我的意思是，就她而言，正如你所说，那肯定绝对是由于狂怒而流下的眼泪。这个小屁孩算什么？她是一个成年女性。我的意思是，她30岁了。女性，我的意思是，她30岁了。我命令你……是的，这是精彩的历史分析，汤姆，非常棒。嗯，所以有他……抱歉，有她，有玛丽。但还有伊丽莎白。现在伊丽莎白20岁了，而且她当然是新教徒。所以问题是，为什么他不直接跳过……
Reason number one is Edward VI, like Henry VIII, doesn't think a woman can be queen. He just thinks, bad idea, end of the Tudors, she'll be dominated by some husband, no one will listen to her, doesn't make sense. So, you know, best not to but of course then that raises the question why does he later go on to jane and the answer i think what he's got but hold on but hold on but also just on elizabeth yeah isn't it also the fact
伊丽莎白？我认为核心原因有两个。原因一：爱德华六世和亨利八世一样，认为女人不能当女王。他就是觉得：这主意太糟了，都铎王朝就此完蛋，她会被某个丈夫主导，没人会听她的，这根本说不通。所以，你知道的，最好别选她……但这就引发了一个问题：为什么他后来又选了简？答案是，我认为他……等等，但是等等……还有，关于伊丽莎白，
she's illegitimate this is it this is absolutely it tom he thinks and he's not wrong because everybody thinks it that mary and elizabeth are both illegitimate now that will seem weird to us because we don't think they're legitimate because of course they were both queens of england but henry the eighth had explicitly said um he goes back to his henry the eighth third succession act so henry the eighth's legislation had explicitly said they are both illegitimate um mary because her mother Catherine of Aragon was married to him illegally, because she'd been married to his brother Arthur before that. And Elizabeth, because Anne Boleyn was a witch, married him through necromancy. And therefore,
难道不是因为她是私生子吗？就是这个，绝对就是这个，汤姆。他认为——而且他没猜错，因为所有人都这么认为——玛丽和伊丽莎白都是私生子。这在我们看来可能会觉得奇怪，因为我们不认为她们是私生子，毕竟她们后来都成了英格兰女王。但亨利八世曾明确表示……他回溯到亨利八世的《第三王位继承法》。所以亨利八世的立法曾明确规定，她们俩都是私生子。玛丽是因为她的母亲阿拉贡的凯瑟琳与他结婚是非法的，因为在此之前她曾嫁给他的哥哥亚瑟；伊丽莎白是因为安妮·博林是个女巫，通过巫术嫁给了他。因此，
Elizabeth was also. And there's no reason to believe that Edward VI, Edward VI completely believes this. He thinks this is, he's thought this all his life. But Dominic, has Henry VIII also not made it a matter of statute that if Edward dies, then Mary and Elizabeth in turn will succeed? Well, this is the crazy ambiguity that in his third succession act and in his will, Henry VIII had basically laid down, yes, they're illegitimate, but in the line of succession, it's Edward first and then Mary and Elizabeth. So it's very ambiguous. And actually a lot of people... Well, you say it's ambiguous, but...
伊丽莎白也是……而且没有理由认为爱德华六世不相信这一点。爱德华六世对此深信不疑。他一辈子都这么认为。但是，多米尼克，难道亨利八世没有通过法令规定，如果爱德华去世，玛丽和伊丽莎白将依次继位吗？这就是疯狂的模棱两可之处。在《第三王位继承法》和遗嘱中，亨利八世基本上规定了：是的，她们是私生子，但在继承顺位上，首先是爱德华，然后是玛丽和伊丽莎白。所以这非常暧昧。实际上很多人……好吧，你说这很暧昧，但是……
Because if they're legitimate, how can they succeed? But it would never have been an issue had Edward not tried to make it an issue. Probably, you're probably right. He's only kind of using it as an excuse, isn't he? I mean, because actually in the event Mary proves to be the people's choice as queen and Elizabeth succeeds without only kind of using it as an excuse, isn't he? I mean, because actually, in the event, Mary proves to be the people's choice as queen and Elizabeth succeeds without any kind of people, with anyone complaining that she's illegitimate. I don't think he's using it purely as an excuse to avoid a Catholic because, I mean,
因为如果她们是私生子，怎么能继承王位呢？但如果爱德华不试图把它变成一个问题，这本永远不会是个问题。可能吧，你大概是对的。他只是把它当成借口，不是吗？我的意思是，因为事实上，最终玛丽证明了自己是人民选择的女王，而伊丽莎白继位时也没有……他只是把它当成借口，不是吗？我的意思是，因为事实上，最终玛丽证明了自己是人民选择的女王，而伊丽莎白继位时也没有遇到任何人抱怨她是个私生子。我不认为他纯粹是用它来作为逃避天主教徒的借口，因为……
why does he skip Elizabeth? Yeah, the king, wanting a male, I think, is also part of it. I think wanting a male is crucial. So here's a key thing to remember, Tom. At this point, he doesn't think he's going to die, and lots of people don't think he's going to die. He's just ill, and in the way that, you know, when you really think about your will, that's what he's thinking about.
为什么他要跳过伊丽莎白？是的，国王渴望一个男性继承人，我认为这也是一部分原因。我认为渴望一个男性继承人至关重要。所以这里有个关键点要记住，汤姆。此时，他并不觉得自己会死，而且很多人也不认为他会死。他只是生病了，就像……你知道的，当你认真考虑立遗嘱时，他想的就是这个。
So in this first version, he says, listen, if I die without an heir, because obviously he thinks that one day he'll get married and have kids. He says, if I die without an heir, it'll go to Lady Jane Grey's male heirs, and if not her, then her sister's sons, and if not her, then her sister's sons. So this is a sort of contingency plan. But then that all changes because on Sunday the 28th of May, which is this crucial day, so we're still in 1553, the doctors, his doctors meet, and they basically have a conference,
所以在第一个版本中，他说：听好了，如果我无嗣而终——因为他显然认为自己有一天会结婚生子——他说，如果我无嗣而终，王位将传给我的表妹简·格雷女士的男性后嗣；如果没有，就传给她姐姐的儿子；如果没有，就传给她姐姐的儿子。所以这是一个应急计划。但随后这一切都变了，因为在5月28日星期日（这是一个关键的日子，我们仍然在1553年），他的医生们开会了，他们基本上进行了会诊，
and they say, he's not getting better. Do you know what? He's actually going to die. And clearly that is communicated to him because in the next two weeks, he goes back over this thing, his device for the succession, and he makes a crucial change. So instead of the crown going to Lady Jane's male heirs or a sister's male heirs, he adds the word and. So now it says Lady Jane and her heirs male. So in other words,
他们说：“他没有好转。你知道吗？他其实快死了。”显然，这一消息传达给了他，因为在接下来的两周里，他重新审视了这件事——他的王位继承计划，并做了一个关键的改动。因此，王位不再传给简女士的男性后嗣或她姐姐的男性后嗣，他加上了“和”（and）这个词。所以现在上面写着：“简女士和她的男性后嗣”。换句话说，
if he drops dead tomorrow, this girl, Lady Jane Grey, will be the next ruler of England. And that's the crucial change. Okay. So I've got an obvious question, a question that is asked by the splendidly named Richard Cromwell. I'm a big fan of Richard Cromwell. Francis Grey, who is Lady Jane's mother and the daughter of Mary, who is the sister of Henry VIII, must have had a better claim than her daughter, if you're excluding Bloody Mary and Mary, Queen of Scots as Catholics. Did anyone think of making Frances Queen? They didn't.
如果他明天突然暴毙，这个女孩——简·格雷女士——将成为英格兰的下一位统治者。这就是关键的改变。好吧。那我有一个显而易见的问题，一个由名字十分响亮的理查德·克伦威尔（Richard Cromwell）提出的问题。我是理查德·克伦威尔的超级粉丝。弗朗西斯·格雷（Francis Grey）——她是简女士的母亲，也是亨利八世姐姐玛丽的女儿——如果你排除血腥玛丽和苏格兰女王玛丽这两个天主教徒不算，她的继承顺位肯定比她的女儿更好吧？有没有人考虑过让弗朗西斯当女王？他们没有。
Because she was past childbearing age by that point. So she wasn't going to have any male heirs. Is that the reason? No, there's still a possibility that she could have a male heir. So why is she excluded? Why don't they exclude her? Why do they her that's an interesting question and other people have asked that uh and the reason is some people think it's because she's thought of as unreliable she's thought of as kind of flighty and difficult but also so not only is francis seen as a bit flighty and flaky and difficult but her husband who is what's his name he's called henry isn't he's henry Henry Grey, Marquess of Dorset. He's descended from Elizabeth Woodville.
因为她当时已经过了生育年龄。所以她不会有什么男性后嗣了。是这个原因吗？不，她还是有可能拥有一个男性后嗣的。那她为什么被排除在外？为什么他们不选她？为什么把她排除在外？这是一个有趣的问题，其他人也问过。原因在于，有些人认为这是因为她被认为不可靠，她被认为有点轻浮、难以相处。不仅弗朗西斯被视为有点轻浮、不可靠和难以相处，还有她的丈夫——他叫什么名字？他叫亨利，对吧？亨利·格雷，多塞特侯爵。他是伊丽莎白·伍德维尔（Elizabeth Woodville）的后代。
Yeah, he is. So all those Greys that were involved in Richard III and everything. Right. But clearly Edward VI doesn't think much of him either. So let's just skip them. So Edward VI is really fiddling with the succession here. And so people sometimes say, well, this is completely illegal. A king can't just pick and choose but of course there was a precedent for that because henry the eighth had been doing that so in a way you again you can understand why edward thinks that because
是的，他是。所以所有那些曾卷入理查德三世事件和其他事情的格雷家族成员……没错。但显然爱德华六世也很看不起他。所以让我们直接跳过他们。因此，爱德华六世在这里确实对继承顺位进行了篡改。所以人们有时会说：好吧，这完全是非法的，国王不能随心所欲地挑选。但当然，这有先例，因为亨利八世就一直在这么做。所以在某种程度上，你再次可以理解为什么爱德华会这么想，因为
he's seen his father fiddle again and again with the succession succession acts and wills and but it's the acts isn't it i mean it's the parliamentary acts. Yeah. Henry VIII had it agreed by parliament. In legislation, yeah. In legislation. So that's the difference, isn't it? Well, Edward doesn't do that. What Edward does is he basically gets everybody to sign a document saying, okay, fine. So with the Privy Council, lots of judges, lots of peers. So they all sign up to this, but it's been done in a great rush because it hasn't really been communicated to the great mass of the public and does it have legal force though if it hasn't been
他看到他的父亲一次又一次地篡改继承顺序、继承法和遗嘱……但那是法律，对吧？我的意思是，那是议会立法。是的，亨利八世得到了议会的同意。通过立法，是的。通过立法。所以这才是区别所在，对吧？嗯，爱德华没有这样做。爱德华做的是，他基本上让所有人都签署了一份文件，上面写着：“好吧，行吧。”所以枢密院、许多法官、许多贵族，他们都在上面签了字，但这是在极度匆忙中完成的，因为它并没有真正传达给广大公众。如果它没有获得议会批准，它具有法律效力吗？
approved by parliament does changing previous act that's been decreed by a king and pass through parliament can can he just do that well this lawyers argue about this he gets lots of lawyers to tell him that it does um but of course they tell him that because that's what he that's that's what he wants to yeah but here's the thing tom if they had told him that he had died lady jane gray had become queen and then been unchallenged or had beaten off mary we wouldn't be doing this podcast and arguing about the legality yeah but she didn't did she and a huge part of the reason why she didn't do it is because it was widely felt to be illegal. A bit odd.
改变由国王颁布并经议会通过的先前法案，他能直接这么做吗？律师们对此争论不休。他找了很多律师来告诉他，这是合法的……但当然，他们之所以这么告诉他，是因为那是他希望听到的。然而关键在于，汤姆：如果他们当时告诉他这是非法的，简·格雷女士在继位后遭到冷遇或者击败了玛丽，我们就不会在这里录制播客并争论其合法性了。是的，但她没有，不是吗？她之所以没有成功的很大一部分原因，正是因为它被普遍认为是非法的。这有点奇怪。
I don't think it's any more illegal necessarily than some of Henry VIII's fiddling, you know, declaring. Because, for example, one of the things that Henry VIII does is Henry VIII skips a whole branch completely, you know, randomly, which is the Scottish branch. So he just leaps over that as though it doesn't exist yeah he does absolutely but he has had it approved by parliament okay fair enough tom tom you know we've been talking for half an hour and i never thought we would spend half an hour talking about genealogy and the constitution okay so i think we should take a break at this
我不认为这一定比亨利八世的一些篡改行为——比如随意宣布废黜——更非法。因为，举个例子，亨利八世做的事情之一，就是完全且随机地跳过了整整一个支脉，也就是苏格兰支脉。他直接跳过了它，就好像它不存在一样。是的，他确实这么干了。但他让议会批准了。好吧，好吧，汤姆。汤姆，你知道的，我们已经聊了半个小时了，我从没想过我们会花半个小时来聊家谱和宪法。好吧，我想我们应该在这个时候休息一下。
point when we come back obviously we, we should talk about Jane herself. We should. We've barely mentioned. But there's also another key figure that we've barely mentioned, and that is John Dudley, the Duke of Northumberland, who is Jane's, not coincidentally, Jane's father-in-law and has been, he's kind of the greatest man in the realm. He is indeed.
等我们回来时，显然，我们应该谈谈简本人。我们应该谈谈。我们几乎还没怎么提到她。但还有一个我们几乎没怎么提到的关键人物，那就是约翰·达德利（John Dudley），诺森伯兰公爵。巧合的是，他不仅是简的公公，而且是王国中最伟大的人物。他确实是的。
He's a controversial figure, Tom. Should we have fun with him? So we'll come back and we will look at John Dudley and we will look at Lady Jane Grey. So don't go away. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
他是一个颇具争议的人物，汤姆。我们要不要拿他开开玩笑？所以我们稍后回来，看看约翰·达德利和简·格雷女士。所以请不要走开。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to the rest is history we are looking at lady jane gray the so-called nine days queen um and as i said before the break we've hardly mentioned her we will i promise but before we come to her let's come uh dominic to john dud. Do you think he spoke with a Dudley accent?
这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目以及抢先购买现场活动门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。哈喽，欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。我们正在关注简·格雷女士，也就是所谓的“九日女王”。正如我在中场休息前所说，我们几乎没怎么提到她。我们会的，我保证。但在我们谈到她之前，多米尼克，让我们先来谈谈约翰·达德利。你觉得他说话带着达德利口音吗？
I don't know. Is that your assumption? I don't believe that he did. So the Dudleys. The Dudleys are one of the great families in Tudor history. Yeah. And, in fact, I commend a new book by Joanne paul just out which uh i was dipping into before this the house of dudley a new history of tudor england um and uh john dudley's father edmund had
我不知道。这是你的假设吗？我不相信他有。所以达德利家族。达德利家族是都铎王朝历史上最伟大的家族之一。是的，事实上，我向大家推荐乔安妮·保罗（Joanne Paul）刚刚出版的新书，我在录音前一直在翻阅它——《达德利家族：都铎英格兰新史》（The House of Dudley: A New History of Tudor England）。约翰·达德利的父亲埃德蒙（Edmund）
basically been an accountant hadn't he yes he got executed by henry the eighth for having been left over from the previous realm it's really important so john dudley has the image of his father you know being executed um yeah and that tells you something about the paranoia that at the at the center of the tudor court is it paranoia i'm not you know paranoia you've got to it's kind of illogical but i mean it's kind of genuinely yeah entirely authentic a completely reasonable exactly yeah yeah so he's been disinherited then he gets he gets you know his father's inheritance back um he's been disinherited. Then he gets his father's inheritance back. He's not really the accountant type, is he? He's much more – he's a kind of Charles Brandon figure.
基本上是个会计，不是吗？是的，他被亨利八世处决了，因为他是前朝留下的遗老。这真的很重要。所以约翰·达德利脑海里有他父亲被处决的画面……是的，这说明了都铎宫廷核心处弥漫的偏执狂。这是偏执狂吗？我不是……偏执狂你得承认……这有点不合逻辑，但我的意思是，它在某种程度上是真实存在的，完全合情合理，对，确实如此。所以他被剥夺了继承权，然后他又找回了父亲的遗产……他被剥夺了继承权，然后又找回了父亲的遗产。他其实不是那种会计型的性格，对吧？他更像是一个——他是个查尔斯·布兰登式的人物。
He's a kind of – in fact, he gets knighted by Charles Brandon, doesn't he? He does. He's less of a kind of roister-doister than Charles Brandon. So he's more – he's a military man. He's a soldier. He's very efficient. So John Dudley – so Northumberlandland as he's always called in the so he has a succession of titles he has first warwick and then northumberland and northumberland he's a duke which is also the kind of so they're only kind of three dukes at
他有点像——事实上，他被查尔斯·布兰登封为了骑士，不是吗？他是的。他不像查尔斯·布兰登那么喜欢寻欢作乐。所以他更多的是一个军人。他是个士兵，非常高效。所以约翰·达德利——也就是通常被称为诺森伯兰的人，所以他有一连串的头衔：他先是沃里克伯爵，然后是诺森伯兰，而诺森伯兰是个公爵，这也是那种……所以当时只有大约三个公爵
that point there are so to be duke of northumberland is a very big deal yeah um so when people tell this story he is always the villain i mean he's the villain of edward the sixth reign he's the villain of the lady jay gray saga and i think most historians would say now that is completely unfair and wrong um so he's always seen as this because he's the sort of chief minister as it were he's seen as this svengali controlling edward the sixth but i think that's very unfair he's a military man as you say um he fought the scots he fought the he fought all the you know all the traditional enemies basically um he's he fought our peasants he's putting down rebellions and stuff yes he put down the what's kett's rebellion kett's rebellion rebellion against
就这一点而言，诺森伯兰公爵这个头衔可是个大人物，是的，嗯，所以每当人们讲述这段历史时，他总是扮演恶棍的角色，我的意思是，他是爱德华六世统治时期的恶棍，是简·格雷夫人传奇中的恶棍，我想现在大多数历史学家会认为这完全不公平且错误，嗯，所以他总是被视为这样的人，因为他是某种意义上的首席大臣，他被视为像斯文加利那样控制爱德华六世的人，但我认为这非常不公平，他是个军人，如你所说，嗯，他与苏格兰人作战，他与，他与所有，你知道的，基本上所有传统敌人作战，嗯，他与我们的农民作战，他镇压叛乱等等，是的，他镇压了凯特叛乱，凯特叛乱，反对
enclosures which is actually very important in the context of this story. So he's seen, people think of him as very efficient, very far-sighted. He had such a head, as somebody says, that he seldom went about anything, but he first conceived three or four purposes beforehand. So he's a planner. He's careful and cautious. And what happens is at the beginning of Edward VI's reign, Edward VI is sort of dominated, because obviously he's only nine, by Jane Seymour's brothers, Edward and Thomas. First of all, they fall out with each other. And then basically everybody falls out with Edward Seymour,
圈地的叛乱，这在整个故事的背景下其实非常重要。所以他被视为，人们认为他非常高效、非常有远见。正如某人所说，他很有头脑，做事很少不先构思好三四个目的。所以他是个谋划者。他小心谨慎。而情况是，在爱德华六世统治初期，爱德华六世在很大程度上受制于简·西摩的兄弟爱德华和托马斯，因为他显然只有九岁。首先，他们互相交恶。然后基本上所有人都与爱德华·西摩交恶，
the Duke of Somerset. And Dudley becomes the sort of figurehead of the movement of all the other bigwigs against him. And Dudley then becomes the big man in Edward VI's council. He's a big Protestant, Tom. He's very into his religious reform. He's very serious about that. He's big on law and order because he thinks the previous sort of administration made a mess of law and order.
也就是萨默塞特公爵。而达德利成了其他所有大人物联合反对他的运动的某种精神领袖。随后，达德利成为了爱德华六世内阁中的风云人物。他是个坚定的新教徒，汤姆。他非常热衷于宗教改革。他对这一点极其认真。他极力主张法律与秩序，因为他认为前一届政府把法治和秩序搞得一团糟。
He's also very big on financial retrenchment. So, you know, he's sort of – I think most people would say he's actually a very good sort of governor, as it were, of England's affairs. So he's kind of – the money is mounting up. He's big on keeping sort of descent to a minimum um he's a he doesn't really i think it's fair to say uh to dominate edward the sixth as much as people used to think so edward the sixth is probably much more of a partner with him i mean obviously they're training edward the sixth to be king but basically dudley's not just just bossing Edward the sixth around. Um, but Dudley is the big man.
他也极力主张紧缩财政。所以，你知道的，他某种程度上——我想大多数人会认为他实际上是英国事务的一个非常优秀的管理者。所以他有点——资金不断累积。他大力主张将异见降到最低，嗯，他，我认为公平地说，他并没有像人们过去认为的那样去支配爱德华六世，所以爱德华六世可能更像是他的伙伴，我的意思是，显然他们正在把爱德华六世培养成国王，但基本上达德利不只是对爱德华六世颐指气使。嗯，但达德利是个大人物。
You know, there's a lot of people who don't like him. There's lots of resentments. Of course. And he has a lot of sons. Um, one of whom of course will go on to become Elizabeth's favorite, Robert Dudley,
你知道的，有很多人不喜欢他。有许多怨恨。当然。而且他有很多儿子。嗯，其中一个儿子后来自然成了伊丽莎白的宠臣罗伯特·达德利，
the Earl of Leicester. Uh, but for our purposes, the key one is, is, uh, he's called Guilford, isn't he?
莱斯特伯爵。嗯，但对我们而言，关键的一个是，嗯，他叫吉尔福德，对吧？
This is the great, what if this is the great, what if Tom in a different world, there's an England a he's called gilford isn't he yeah now this is the great what if this is the great what if tom in a different world there's an england that had a king gilford king gilford king gilford the first and the people of gilford would be delighted with that wouldn't i mean not necessarily borough of gilford wouldn't they they would and i'm not knocking gilford at all but it's not the most automatically glamorous of places and in many ways the great tragedy of this story is that works out so badly for the people of guildford um who miss out on their chance royal glory exactly so so guildford marries lady jane tremendous catch for him um yes but the the question then is so it's usually assumed that um northumberland is doing the kind of equivalent of insider dealing, that he knows what's coming.
这就是那个伟大的“如果”，汤姆，在另一个世界里，有一个英国，他叫吉尔福德，对吧？现在，这就是那个伟大的“如果”，汤姆，在另一个世界里，有一个曾拥有吉尔福德国王的英国，吉尔福德国王第一世，吉尔福德的人民一定会为此高兴的，不是吗？我是说，不一定是指吉尔福德镇，对吧？他们会的，我并不是在贬低吉尔福德，但它并不是那种最自然而然充满魅力的敌方，在许多方面，这个故事的悲剧在于，这对吉尔福德的人民来说结果太糟糕了，他们错失了迎来皇室荣耀的机会，完全正确。所以，吉尔福德娶了简夫人，这对他来说是个了不起的好姻缘，是的，但问题是，通常人们会认为，诺森伯兰在做某种类似内幕交易的事，他知道接下来会发生什么。
He's had a look at Edward VI's device. And so he's pairing his son up with the girl who may well become Queen of England. But it's possible, isn't it, that actually it's the other way around? Exactly right. It's Edward VI who is pushing it. Yeah, it's possible, isn't it, that actually it's the other way around? Exactly right. It's Edward VI who is pushing it. Yeah, it's exactly right. So what we don't know is if this whole scheme was cooked up by John Dudley or whether it was cooked up by Edward VI. who does treat it as a kind of whodunit and really digs into the motives of all the sort of the suspects and sort of the forensic analysis of the documents. And he says, you know, it's actually not clear that the Guildford marriage is just because he knows Jane will be queen.
他看过爱德华六世的遗诏。因此，他把自己的儿子和那个很可能成为英国女王的女孩撮合在一起。但有没有可能，事实上情况恰恰相反呢？完全正确。是爱德华六世在极力推动此事。是的，有没有可能，事实上情况恰恰相反呢？完全正确。是爱德华六世在极力推动此事。是的，完全正确。所以我们不知道这个整个计划是由约翰·达德利策划的，还是由爱德华六世策划的。他把这当作一桩悬疑案来处理，并真正深入挖掘所有嫌疑人的动机，对文件进行了法医学般的分析。他说，你知道的，吉尔福德的婚姻并不一定是因为他知道简会成为女王。
That actually the Guildford marriage to Jane may just be an absolutely standard court marriage. And that actually, at this point, Edward may not have changed his plans so that Jane herself will inherit. So if Northumberland had put his son up to this, he'd be playing a hell of a long game. Because, I mean, it would be his grandchildren that would inherit the throne. It's a long time in the future. Yeah, but it's still something to think about. It is still something. And, of course, I'm sure there was a degree of self-interest.
实际上，吉尔福德与简的联姻可能只是一场绝对标准的宫廷联姻。而且在这一时期，爱德华可能还没有改变他的计划，好让简本人来继承王位。所以，如果诺森伯兰是怂恿儿子这么做的话，他就是在下一盘很大很大的棋。因为，我的意思是，继承王位的将是他的孙辈。那是很久以后的事了。是的，但这也是值得思考的事情。这确实是一件事。而且，当然，我相信其中也包含了一定程度的自私。
Of course. I mean, there would be. That's completely natural in a Tudor courtier. But I think to see Dudley as the mastermind of the sort of conspirator plotting all this, I think robs Edward VI of agency. I think it's Edward VI's project, actually. So we have a question from Dr. Danny Witch-Hunting Buck. Do you feel it was Edward's idealism or Dudley's ambition that put Lady Jane on the throne? I suppose your answer to that, and I
当然。我的意思是，肯定会有。这对于都铎王朝的朝臣来说是再自然不过的事了。但我觉得把达德利看作是策划这一切的阴谋家或幕后主使，这剥夺了爱德华六世的主动性。我认为这实际上是爱德华六世的计划。所以，我们有一个来自“猎巫”丹尼·巴克博士的问题。你觉得把简夫人推上王位的是爱德华的理想主义，还是达德利的野心？我想你对这个问题的回答是，我
don't want to put words into your mouth, but I'm going to, is that you would say that Dudley had a measure of idealism as well, that he's obviously ambitious, but presumably he shares Edward's anxiety about, well, definitely Mary, because Mary and Northumberland hate each other. But there's also a kind of religious dimension to that. Northumberland is a radical Protestant, doesn't want Catholics back. He thinks it will guarantee a Protestant England. It happens to suit him. You know, his son will be effectively king.
不想替你回答，但我还是要说，你会认为达德利也具备一定程度的理想主义，他显然很有野心，但大概他也分担了爱德华对玛丽的焦虑，当然是因为玛丽和诺森伯兰彼此仇恨。但其中也有某种宗教维度。诺森伯兰是个激进的新教徒，不希望天主教徒卷土重来。他认为这能确保英国成为一个新教国家。这恰好也符合他的利益。你知道的，他的儿子实际上会成为国王。
So idealism and ambition kind of concur. Right. I don't think he thinks oh i've masterminded this huge thing this is my my splendid fiendish plot um and uh it's pretty clear that he hasn't planned every detail in the way that he normally does so you've got this meticulous hard-nosed planner who is desperately improvising and making stuff up as he goes along and and people think that at the time, don't they? Because this is the age of Machiavelli, and the image of the Machiavelli, a sinister kind of figure plotting and pulling strings behind the scenes, has become part of the mental furniture of people in this period.
所以理想主义和野心在某种程度上是不谋而合的。没错。我不认为他会想：“哦，我策划了这么一件大事，这是我极其精妙、阴险的阴谋，”嗯，而且很明显，他并没有像平时那样计划好每一个细节。所以你看到了这个一丝不苟、精明强干的策划者，他正在拼命地即兴发挥，见招拆招，而当时的人们也确实是这么认为的，不是吗？因为这是马基雅维利主义的时代，而马基雅维利那种在幕后密谋、操纵傀儡的阴险人物形象，已经成为那个时代人们固有思维的一部分。
And so I guess that that must be part of why Northumberland comes to get such a dark reputation is that people associate him with Machiavellian devices and all that kind of stuff. Do you think? Yeah, I think that's absolutely right. I think it also, when the whole thing unravels, everybody blames him. You know, all the other people who were in on it. Which is convenient, isn't it? He's a convenient scapegoat. I mean, there is a slight tradition, isn't there, in Tudor England of basically the last king's chief minister gets the
所以我想，这一定也是诺森伯兰名声变得如此不堪的原因之一，因为人们将他与马基雅维利的诡计和诸如此类的事情联系在一起。你觉得呢？是的，我认为完全正确。我认为当整件事情败露时，所有人也都把责任归咎于他。你知道的，所有其他参与其中的人。这很方便，不是吗？他是一个方便的替罪羊。我的意思是，在都铎时期的英格兰，确实存在着一种轻微的传统，即上一任国王的首席大臣一旦继任者上台，
chop as soon as the successor comes in. So there's a sense in which that happened to his own father. His dad. Yeah. And he basically ends up, it's the same story again. I mean, he basically carries the can for all the resentments that are piled up at the end of the reign of Edward VI. And I think there is that dimension in early modern history generally, isn't there?
就会立刻被砍头。所以在某种意义上，他自己的父亲也遭遇了这种事。他的父亲。是的。而他基本上也落得这个下场，这又是同一个故事。我的意思是，他基本上背负了爱德华六世统治末期积聚的所有怨恨。而且我认为在早期现代历史中普遍存在着这样一个维度，不是吗？
The sort of cardinal richelieu, the eminence grise, the power behind the throne. And that's what historians talk about, the sort of black legend of Northumberland as this sort of plotter par excellence. But it's also with the idea of the Machiavelli that it's power for power's sake, that there's not a shred of idealism about it, that it's just about doing down your rivals and making yourself top dog. And clearly that's not all it is for Northumberland. I mean, it must be a huge part of it,
类似于黎塞留枢机主教、幕后权臣、王权背后的权力。这也是历史学家们所谈论的，关于诺森伯兰作为这种顶尖阴谋家的“黑色传奇”。但这也伴随着马基雅维利主义的观点，即为权力而权力，其中没有一丝理想主义，纯粹是为了打倒竞争对手并让自己成为老大。显然，诺森伯兰并不完全是这样。我的意思是，这肯定占了很大一部分，
but that's not all it is. Okay, so that's Northumberland. Now, what about the lady herself, Lady Jane Grey, who, of course, isn't Lady Jane Grey by this point, is she? She must be Lady Jane Dudley. Well, she's Jane Grey when she, yes, she becomes. I hadn't thought of that. She does become Jane Dudley, but at this point she's Jane Grey.
但绝不仅限于此。好了，这就是诺森伯兰。那么，关于女主角本身——简·格雷夫人，她到这个时候当然已经不再叫简·格雷夫人了，对吧？她当时一定成了简·达德利夫人。嗯，当她，是的，她成为。我之前没想到这一点。她确实成为了简·达德利，但在当时她还是简·格雷。
So what can we say about her? Well, as always, I think, with Tudor England, as a sort of modern historian looking at this period, I think what's so interesting about it is that the sources are so tantalizing. They give you just enough that you can construct a kind of personality out of these historical characters. But actually, you know, the imagination is doing an enormous amount of the legwork. So we actually know quite, you know, it's frustrating how little we know about Jane. But actually what we know about her
那么我们能对她作何评价呢？嗯，就像在都铎时期的英国一样，作为一个研究这一时期的现代历史学家，我认为最有趣的地方在于，这些史料实在太诱人了。它们恰好提供了足够的线索，让你能从这些历史人物身上构建出一种性格。但实际上，你的想象力在其中发挥了极其巨大的作用。所以我们其实知道很多，你知道的，令人沮丧的是我们对简的了解少之又少。但实际上我们所了解的关于她的事，
is all to her credit by and large so she's born probably in 1537 i mean we don't even know the year we can't even be absolutely certain of the year she's uh probably born um or brought up in this house bradgate park near leicester so it it's sort of one of the great brick mansions that belong to the Grey family. Her parents are very young when she's born, so they're probably 20 and 21, respectively. What we know about her is that we have one physical description that comes from a Genoese merchant who sees her later on after the whole nine-day queen in Brolio.
大体上都为她增光添彩。所以她大概出生于1537年，我的意思是，我们甚至不知道她的出生年份，我们甚至无法百分之百确定她的年份，她大概出生在，嗯，或者说是在莱斯特附近的布拉德盖特公园这座房子里长大的。这是属于格雷家族的宏伟大砖宅邸之一。她出生时父母还很年轻，大概分别只有20岁和21岁。我们对她所了解的，来自于热那亚的一位商人留下的一份外貌描述，这位商人在布罗利奥那场为期九天的女王事件之后见到了她。
And he says, She has small features and a well-made nose, the mouth flexible and the lips red. The eyebrows are arched and darker than her hair, which is nearly red. Her eyes are sparkling and reddish brown in colour. I stood so near her, Grace, that I noticed her colour was good but freckled. When she smiled, she showed her teeth, which are white and sharp. In all, a gracious and animated figure okay
他说：她五官小巧，鼻子线条优美，嘴唇灵活红润。眉毛呈弧形，颜色比几乎是红色的头发要深。她的眼睛闪闪发光，呈红褐色。格雷阁下，我当时离她那么近，注意到她的气色很好，但有雀斑。她微笑时露出了洁白而锐利的牙齿。总而言之，这是一个优雅而生动的人物形象。好吧，
so on her on the question of schooling uh the reputation is that she's a brilliant mind right she kind of speaks nine languages and can construe hebrew and all kinds of stuff is is that accurate where is that coming from so this comes from it's the classic tudor history thing where there's the one source the one fragment on which people have built up a whole edifice of speculation but basically there's a humanist scholar called roger asham who in 1550 so how old is she then she's about 13 he visits braggade and lester to visit her tutor who's another great humanist called John Aylmer. And, of course, this is the great age of humanist scholars. And Asher says, because he wrote about it, he said, Before I went to Germany, I came to Broadgate in Leicestershire
那么关于她的学业问题，普遍的传言是她有着绝顶聪明的头脑，对吧？她会说九种语言，能解读希伯来语等等各种语言，这是真的吗？这种说法从何而来？所以这来自于——典型的都铎历史现象，即人们仅凭单一的来源或碎片就构建出了一整座猜测的大楼。但基本上，有一位名叫罗杰·阿沙姆的人文主义学者，在1550年——那么她当时多大呢？她大约13岁——他来到莱斯特的布拉德盖特拜访她的家庭教师，那是另一位伟大的人文主义者，名叫约翰·艾尔默。当然，这也是人文主义学者的伟大时代。阿沙姆说，因为他对此有过记载，他说：在我去德国之前，我来到了莱斯特郡的布拉德盖特，
to take my leave of that noble lady, Jane Grey, to whom I was exceedingly much beholding. He says, Everybody else in the household was out hunting in the park, but I found her in her chamber reading Phaedo Platonis in Greek, so reading Plato. And that with as much delight as some gentleman would read a merry tale in Boccaccio. And after salutation and duty done with some other talk, I asked her why she would lose such pastime in the park. Why isn't she off in the park with everybody else smiling she answered me i whist all their sport in the park is but a shadow to that pleasure that i find in plato alas good folk they
去向那位我深感感激的尊贵女子简·格雷告别。他说，家里的其他人都在公园里打猎，但我发现她在自己的房间里用希腊语阅读柏拉图的《斐多篇》，也就是说在读柏拉图。而且她阅读时的喜悦，就像某些绅士阅读薄伽丘的滑稽故事一样。在行过礼节、寒暄并进行了一些其他交谈后，我问她为什么要在公园里错过这样的消遣。为什么她不和其他人一起去公园面带微笑呢？她回答我说：公园里所有的运动，比起我在柏拉图身上找到的乐趣，不过是个影子罢了。唉，这些善良的人们，
never felt what true pleasure meant and she you know she can't get enough plato oh no well that redounds immensely to her credit rather than going off and having fun. But there is a catch. So he basically says, you know, what's all that about? You're a teenager. Shouldn't you be out like, you know, killing animals with the rest of your family? And she says, well, I'll tell you a truth which maybe you'll marvel at. One of the greatest benefits that God ever gave me, says Jane, is that he sent me so sharp and severe parents and so gentle a schoolmaster. Because she says, you know, my schoolmaster, your mate,
他们从来没有体会过什么是真正的乐趣。而她，你知道的，她对柏拉图百读不厌。哦，不，这为她赢得了极大的赞誉，而不是出去玩乐。但这里有个问题。所以他基本上说，你知道的，这到底是怎么回事？你还是个青少年。难道你不应该像其他人一样去杀死动物吗？她说，好吧，我来告诉你一个可能会让你感到惊奇的真相。简说，上帝给我的最大恩赐之一，就是送给我如此严厉苛刻的父母和如此温和的家庭教师。因为她说，你知道的，我的家庭教师，你的朋友，
gives me all these books and we talk about this. Lovely. But when I'm in the presence of my father and my mother, whether I speak, keep silent, sit, stand or go, eat, drink, be merry or sad, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. I must do it so perfectly as God made the world, or else I'm so sharply taunted, so cruelly threatened with pinches, nips, and bobs that I think myself in hell.
给我所有这些书，我们讨论这些。这很好。但每当我出现在父亲和母亲面前时，无论我说话、保持沉默、坐着、站着、行走、吃东西、喝酒、高兴还是悲伤，等等等等。我都必须做得像上帝创造世界一样完美，否则我就会遭到严厉的嘲讽，遭到掐、拧和弹脑门等残酷的威胁，以至于我认为自己身处地狱。
So in other words, she basically is escaping from being pinched by her parents. Yeah. I mean, if she's not good at killing animals, then that's awful, isn't it? Well, I mean, you can imagine her father kind of, no, not like that. Like that. Shoot it. Maybe. So basically, in Tudor historiographical style, people have spent entire careers arguing about. Well, there's enough grift there for a novel, isn't there?
换句话说，她基本上是在逃避父母的虐待。嗯。我的意思是，如果她不擅长杀死动物，那可就太糟糕了，不是吗？嗯，我的意思是，你可以想象她的父亲那种态度：“不，不是那样的。要这样。开枪射击它。”也许吧。所以基本上，在都铎时期的历史写作风格中，人们花了一整个职业生涯在争论。嗯，这里有足够吸引人的素材来写一部小说，不是吗？
Is she exaggerating? Is she a stroppy teenager just saying oh my parents treat me they don't understand me they pinch me um or is this the truth uh and and is she this tremendous mind i mean she's by the way there was one other thing about her it's a man called sir thomas challoner he said this would have definitely appealed to you tom he said um she had joined chaldean words to the language of the Arabs with a skillful grasp of the idiom of the Hebrews. For to mention her speaking on Greek or Latin would be a small account. Other women speak these languages in civilized places.
她在夸大其词吗？她是一个叛逆的青少年，只是在说“哦，我的父母这样对待我，他们不理解我，他们掐我”，嗯，还是这才是真相？她是否拥有如此惊人的头脑？我的意思是，顺便说一句，关于她还有另一件事，一个叫托马斯·查洛纳爵士的人说过——这绝对会吸引你，汤姆。他说，她将迦勒底语融入了阿拉伯人的语言中，并对希伯来语的习语有着精湛的掌握。至于提到她说希腊语或拉丁语，那就微不足道了。其他文明地方的女性也会说这些语言。
Likewise, Gallic and Etruscan speech had added their number to this English lady. If you were to number her languages, this one lady spoke eight. So, Tom, do you speak chaldean chaldean chaldean all right well whatever it is i think that's all very improbable do you think she speaks etruscan no because nobody speaks etruscan unless by etruscan they mean tuscan i.e italian well i don't know i don't i i don't know but if it's etruscan then that's that then that's clearly a lie because nobody speaks Etruscan because they still haven't deciphered it. So there are some people who say, historians who say,
同样，高卢语和伊特鲁里亚语也为这位英国女士的语言库增添了数量。如果你要数一数她的语言，这位女士一共会说八种。所以，汤姆，你会说迦勒底语吗？迦勒底语，迦勒底语。好吧，不管是什么，我认为这一切都太不可思议了。你觉得她会说伊特鲁里亚语吗？不会，因为没有人会说伊特鲁里亚语，除非他们说的伊特鲁里亚语指的是托斯卡纳语，也就是意大利语。嗯，我不知道，我不知道，我不知道，但如果是伊特鲁里亚语，那这显然是个谎言，因为没有人会说伊特鲁里亚语，因为他们至今还没有破译它。所以有些人说，有些历史学家说，
this is humanists, humanist scholars. Kind of boasting. Massively exaggerating. They're also, her father actually, I mean, you did an impersonation of him as a sort of huntsman, but actually her father is quite into this. So he's a patron for a lot of them and and a good contact so they probably want to butter him up by like bigging him up in their
这些人是人文主义者，人文主义学者。有点在吹牛。大肆夸大。他们也是——其实她的父亲，我的意思是，你刚才模仿了他作为一个猎人的样子，但实际上她的父亲对这些很感兴趣。所以他是他们许多人的赞助人，也是一个很好的联系人，所以他们可能想通过在写给彼此的信中把他说得很厉害来拍他的马屁，
letters to each other so there's a there's an element of that about it as well but the the jane jane saying oh i i hate them they you know they're constantly criticizing me yeah that does sound kind of i mean you can imagine her father like kind of competitive dad in the far show yeah i mean i don't think there's any reason to doubt that um it's the one thing we know i mean that's also and i think that there's no reason to doubt she's a great reader she loves speaking languages she likes talking to scholars that is absolutely consistent and i mean the reason we can be pretty sure it's consistent is that when we get to the end of her life when she's in the tower you know she's writing letters tower, you know, she's writing letters, she's reading the Bible, she's been very, very serious
所以这里面也有这方面的因素。但是简说“哦，我恨他们，他们总是挑剔我”，嗯，这听起来确实有点——我的意思是，你可以想象她的父亲就像表演秀里那种好胜的父亲。嗯，我的意思是，没有任何理由怀疑这一点，嗯，这是我们知道的唯一一件事，我的意思是，这也是——而且我认为没有理由怀疑她是一个伟大的阅读者，她喜欢说各种语言，她喜欢与学者交谈，这是完全一致的。我的意思是，我们可以相当确定它是一致的原因是，当她走到生命尽头，当她在伦敦塔时，你知道的，她在写信，
and having theological arguments with people. So she's absolutely, I mean, she is another red hot Protestant. Yeah. So that's the key thing, isn't it? Really? I mean, it doesn't really matter for the purposes of Edward VI or Northumberland, how clever she is, how many ancient languages she can read, any of that. What matters is her bloodline and the fact that she is as committed and white-hot a Protestant as they are. Yeah. And that's all that matters. I think that's right. So to return to the sort of narrative.
在伦敦塔，你知道的，她在写信，她在读《圣经》，她表现得非常非常严肃，并与人进行神学辩论。所以她绝对——我的意思是，她是另一个狂热的新教徒。嗯。所以这才是关键所在，不是吗？真的？我的意思是，对于爱德华六世或诺森伯兰来说，她有多聪明、她能读懂多少种古代语言，这些都不重要。重要的是她的血统，以及她和他们一样坚定、狂热地信仰新教。嗯。而这才是唯一重要的。我想是的。所以让我们回到叙事上来。
So Jane marries gilford dudley um their their contract their sort of the arrangement is made gilford gets food poisoning doesn't he at the at the wedding well the douglas have terrible trouble with their health so so john dudley is a hypochondriac who apparently has this stomach ulcer or stomach issues that mean he's often missing so yeah as well as being this incredibly impressive military man um he's got this he's a he's a martyr to his stomach well because they hardly ever spend any time together because um gilford gets gets food poisoning at the wedding he's sick for a month and then he recovers and jane immediately gets food poisoning so yeah so so difficult for the happy couple jane's illness may be stressed by the way she may be she may be conscious that
简嫁给吉尔福德·达德利，嗯，他们的婚约，这种安排达成了。吉尔福德在婚礼上食物中毒了，对吧？嗯，达德利家族的健康状况糟糕透顶，所以——约翰·达德利是一个疑病症患者，据说他有胃溃疡或肠胃问题，这导致他经常缺席，所以，是的，除了作为一个令人印象深刻的军人之外，嗯，他还有这方面的毛病，他是自己胃病的受害者。嗯，因为他们几乎没有在一起度过多少时间，因为嗯，吉尔福德在婚礼上食物中毒了，他病了一个月，然后他康复了，而简立刻也食物中毒了，所以，是的，对这对幸福的夫妇来说真是太艰难了。顺便说一句，简的生病可能是因为压力，她可能意识到
some terrible you know um crisis is looming and she may be you know she may have detected a change in the atmosphere but also funny that they're very young i mean she's what's what, 15 or so. So they get married. Do we know how old Guilford is? Guilford is maybe a couple of years older. He's maybe 17 or so. So they get married. They have been married for basically only nine weeks or so by the time that she becomes, as in a vertical,
某种可怕的危机正在逼近，她可能察觉到了气氛的变化。但也有趣的是他们非常年轻，我的意思是她大概15岁左右。所以他们结婚了。我们知道吉尔福德多大吗？吉尔福德可能大几岁。他大概17岁左右。所以他们结婚了。在她成为，实际上是在名义上成为女王的时候，他们结婚基本上只有九周左右，他们是否已经圆房还不确定，在食物中毒不断发生的情况下，这太不性感了。但我也觉得开始时人们说他们结婚了，但他们不会圆房，因为他们都还很年轻，而且他们没有同居，所以他们花了很多时间分开，但人们并没有期望他们同居。我不觉得这是一种强迫的，你知道的，有时在浪漫小说对简·格雷夫人的描述中，她被迫嫁给吉尔福德·达德利，根本没有那种感觉。人们这样评价他，某人说——
as a queen, whether they have, they have consummated the marriage is uncertain with food poisoning going on that's that that's very unsexy but also i think it's said at the beginning people sort of say they're married but they're not going to consummate it because they're both very young and there's a they're not cohabiting so they are spending a lot of time apart but they're not expected to cohabit i don't think there's any sense that this is a a forced you know sometimes in the romantic novel kind of account of lady jane gray she's been forced to marry gilford dudley there's no sense of that people sort of say of him what does somebody
他个子有点高，金发碧眼，有人说他是一个英俊、善良、端庄的绅士。他是个不错的对象，你知道的，他是王国外除国王之外最有权势的人的儿子。但他只是第四个儿子，对吧？是的，但我的意思是，他仍然是个不错的对象。你知道的，他是王国外除国王之外最有权势的人的儿子。但他只是第四个儿子，对吧？是的，但我的意思是，他仍然，他不会继承太多财产，而且他总是生病，
he's he's a bit tall he's blonde haired somebody says he is a comely virtuous and goodly gentleman he's a decent catch you know he's the son of the most powerful man apart from the king in the in the realm he's only the fourth son though isn't he he is but i mean it's still he's a decent catch. You know, he's the son of the most powerful man apart from the king in the, in the realm. He's only the fourth son though, isn't he? He is, but I mean, it's still, he's not going to inherit much and he's always being sick,
除此之外别无其他。是的。但她总是阅读柏拉图，还用伊特鲁里亚语写信。我的天，真是绝配啊！
but apart from that. Yeah. But she's always reading Plato and like writing, you know, letters in Etruscan. I mean, what, what,
多好的一对啊。有些人可能会说这是一对绝配。你知道的，多米尼克，我们完成了常规流程。我们已经聊了一个小时了。我们确实聊了一个小时。但让我们以一个悬念结尾吧，汤姆，我想这样能让大家高兴。
what, what a couple. Some people might say this is a great couple. Do you know, Dominic, we've done our usual. We've been talking for about an hour. We have. But let's just get, let's end on a cliffhanger, Tom, I think, to keep the people happy.
让我们以一个悬念结尾，因为我们实际上必须制作第二集来讲述接下来发生的故事。但我们已经设定好了动态。我们设定好了人物。整整一集播客都在讲序幕。把我们带到真实故事的边缘吧。好的。所以，在7月6日星期四，爱德华六世去世了。
Let's end on a cliffhanger because we're going to have to do a second episode actually telling the story of what then happens. But we've set up the dynamic. We've set up the characters. A whole podcast on a prologue. Take us to the brink of the actual story. Right. So on Thursday, the 6th of July, Edward VI dies.
正如通常的情况一样，亨利七世和亨利八世时期也是如此，他的父亲和祖父都是如此。整个过程笼罩在神秘之中。基本上，当君主去世时，对王国来说这是一个极其不稳定的时刻。你需要掌控一切。当亨利八世去世时，他们在街上部署了军队。在消息泄露之前，他们派人把守着城门。这显然又是再次发生的情况。
And as is often the way, as was the case with Henry VII and with Henry VIII, with his father and his grandfather. The whole thing is shrouded in secrecy. Basically, it's an incredibly unstable moment for a kingdom when the monarch dies. You need to get everything. When Henry VIII had died, they had troops in the streets. They'd had people guarding the gates before they allowed the news to get out. This is clearly what happens again.
爱德华六世在7月6日星期四去世。消息一点也没有走漏。在9日星期日，简被带去见他的内阁大臣们。而她根本不知道即将发生什么。这是在锡安宫，对吧？在里士满。是的，我正要说伦敦西部，但那是里士满。她被带了进去，大臣们，包括她的公公、诺森伯兰公爵约翰·达德利，他们向她鞠躬并说：“国王已经驾崩，你
Edward VI dies on Thursday, the 6th of July. And no news has got out at all. On Sunday, the 9th, Jane is shown in to see his counsellors. And she has no idea what is coming. And this is at Scion House, isn't it? In Richmond. Yes, I was about to say West London, but it's Richmond. She is shown in and the counsellors, including her father-in-law, John Dudley, Duke of Northumberland, they bow to her and they say, the king is dead and you
就是女王。”他拿着这份文件，王位属于你。而她对此的反应——我想你可以说，汤姆，甚至在这个阶段，麻烦就要来了，因为她对此的反应不是“万岁，女王”，而是放声大哭。就在这一刻，她对此产生了严重的怀疑。当然，接下来的一切就开始走下坡路了。好吧。伴随着满脸泪痕的简夫人、简女王在锡安宫的大长廊里的情景，我们将暂停我们的故事，并将在第二部分中回归——这个故事不可避免地变成了
are the queen. He has got this document and the crown goes to you. And her reaction to that, and I guess you could say, Tom, even at this stage, there is going to be trouble because her reaction to that is not hurrah, queen. It is to break down in floods of tears. And she has serious doubts about this right at this moment. And of course, the rest is downhill. Okay. So with a tear streaked Lady Jane, Queen Jane in the Great Gallery at Scion House, we will pause our story and we will come back in the second part of what has inevitably turned
上下两部分。所以我们回头见。我们很快就会带着第二部分与大家见面。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家分集、提前解锁、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。
out to be a two part story. So we will see you. We'll see you with part two very soon. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家分集以及提前购买现场门票的权限，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可留下评论。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这里是您每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点八卦的地方，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐行业的神秘面纱，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果您想享受无广告收听、额外单集以及优先购买现场门票的权益，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。